είχα εδ κατούτο και τη ψυσή μου αδογάτοτι να τογάτω τα ούλα και θερα τότε
να πάει γιατί πασου κάτι πριν ότι ο κόσμος τώρα τελευταίος βλέπε με διαφορατικά ατο
κάτου τα ούλα δκαι ξεπαρασε μ ξεπέρασεμε και αλομε να έκαμε μεκαι η μάνας πούμε
και όικάλαμε των ευρο βουλευτ ε με καιόν το ποσωστό και γυρί και τη νύχτα
που ευκή κινιμου μαζί του στασπίτι μου μόνος που έποια με πήα εμπά στο χορκό
άι στα κάμαμε κιώνα ανείχειτικών του χριστό δουλίδη ότι πρόεραρτου ένα σε βοηθήσουμε έτα σουγά
ότκακεταλοιπά έμας απάντησε ναιβοή λοιπόν μετά πόφεύκοπαρουμανία αι ρκουμε πίσω τέλος πάντω και περνά λιο
κερό και βκαε ένα νείχιτικό κόσι ευά λεπθά ντας ευκή και να υρώβουλευτής και δενμε
αναφερικά λοιπόη γυναίκα μου ήρεμέναμε πυραξέδι ότ αςοπό ότι ην αλήθεια ότι εγώ και τους
τέις τερις μέρες μετω των μιτσ δώ κάτου ταμενούλααλλά πια σα πράγματα εγώ ίμαθα πράγματα
πον των μίτσιμο τα αέμαθα για ταό αλμύτια έμα θα πολλά πράγματα που είνα της
ώρααμε και μέχο εν έχω παράπονών ας πούμε το το το πράγμαδήραδιλάγιραμό να μιλώσου ξοδα
ξέιση γυναίγα μου επιράκτηκε πολλάδι ότι μέχρι και την ίδια νέβαλα πιο μέρες πριντες εκλωγές
γκαιςιραμόρα πό όταν να ποτές τις ζωέντήας και ξέσιρα μόνα να αγαπηδή στον κόσμο βοηθήσαμε
των πολλά τέλος ποτα αμέσω ου τα πολόγο μετά που ι υτωμάδες έρκετε βρίσκειμει ναλή
μου εγώννα πό αναμείνω στην ευρώπη που μεπολλο ανιαφέρει κύπρο να γαπόταδικά που κικά το
θέλακάπω να κοστούμε στο παγκόσμιο πολλά καλάεγώ πάω τκαι ξέι ααποφάσα γάμο κι τσις ραοπελλού
και αλά λοιόδεν τοενατα καπρλατοφο ενσις γυναίκα υβρα μια λαδή μου και αιμε κατάλαβα ότι
σήμερα μιλάτε τελευταία φορά που μιλήσαμε είδαν που τούστε ελά να ανίχειτικό τότε ποκαμετών το
βείτο για την κύπρον και πμίλησα του για τη νημημάθεια και πισεις κάμα το ένα
λεφτερομβγίδ κ πατο